Ethan: Hey, Justin. We got you. I see Joey doing push-ups right now. How delayed is the stream?
Justin: Yeah, yeah, he's warmin' up, he's warmin' up.
Justin: Alright, so we're uh... Do you wanna stay on the phone with me? I don't know if you can hear us.
Ethan: I can hear you. I can see you. I'm watching this and I'm just thinking I'm not worthy. This is way too beautiful.
Justin: Okay, okay. So, you guys are gonna comment, I'm gonna hang up, and we're gonna do this.
Ethan: Yeah, absolutely. I mean, we--
the sound was better before. What happened?
Hila: Should we show it fullscreen, like without the layout?
Ethan: Should I keep Justin on the call? Before, it was louder.
Justin: Oh, um, it might've been 'cause we were closer to the camera.
Ethan: Okay, I'll keep you on the call. Just talk-- talk us through it.
Justin: K--Keep me on the call, keep me on the call. Alright, alright.
Justin: Are we good? Are we ready?
Ethan: You're ready. Wait, hold on.
Hila: Should we have it completely full screen?
Ethan: No, it's great. You can see it all. Alright, tell Joey... tell Joey, "Thank you."
Justin: Dude, we're about to do this shit.
Ethan: Tell Joey, "Thank you for the hurricane victims." Thank you, Joey Salads for taking it to the face.
Justin: The hurricane victims are thanking you, Joey Salads. Here we go.
Here we go.
All right. Shit, here we go. Okay, so you can see this shit, right, Ethan? Yeah?
Ethan: Oh, we see it.
Justin: Alright, here we go. I'm doin' it. 3... 2... 1...
*laughing*
Justin: Is that even doing anything?
Oh, shit. Open your eyes
Justin: You gotta open your eyes.
*laughing*
Justin: Here, here. Look up at the sky. Ready?
There you go, there you go.
Ethan: Put the phone up to Joey.
Put him on. How's he doing?
Justin: Oh, man. He's hurtin'.
This is why cops use this to deter you, and also why potential victims of sexual assault use this method of uh... you know...
Justin: Oh, you definitely need water, Joey.
Man: We don't want him walking back in here with that milk dripping off of him.
Justin: Drink the milk!
Ethan: Can we a-- Can we get a word from him?
Justin: Can you get a what?
Ethan: A word from Joey
Justin: Oh, yeah. Joey, here. They wanna hear from you.
*laughing*
Joey, how are you feeling? You okay?
Joey: This is a stupid idea! Why would I do this?!
Justin: He's blind right now.
He got hit pretty hard.
Ethan: *laughing* You all need to be donating right now.
Woman: We are doing this for you to give us money!
Justin: Come on, open your fucking peepers.
Ethan: Joey, open your peepers. Let Jus--
Let Justin help you, Joey.
Ethan: Look at the-- People are walking by in the background.
*laughing*
Justin: *laughs* People walking by are like, "What the fuck is going on?!"
You feeling any better?
Ethan: P-- Put him up-- Put the phone up to him. Let's hear from him.
Man: Good Lord
Woman: Hard to watch.
*Ethan coughs*
Justin: How much research did you do in regards to--
*Ethan squeals*
Justin: He says-- I said, "How much research did you do
in regards to, you know, overcoming this?" and he said, "Zero."
Ethan: Wait, wait, wait, wait. I-- I asked him specifically. 'Cause I was like, "You've done-- have you done this before? 'Cause I don't want you to get too f--
He said, "I've done it twice before."
Hila: I asked him, too, but he told me, "Before, it was watered down," and this time, it's not.
It was watered down before.
Justin: The milk expires September 20th. What's the date?
Ethan: He's good, he's good.
Justin: Oh, okay. He's good.
Ethan: That's-- That's fresh milk, that's fresh milk.
Justin: I got my dates mixed up.
Ethan: As much as I'd love for that to be rotten milk, it's fresh.
*Hila laughs*
Ethan: Is he alright?
It's interesting how he just dumps it on his face.
How are you feeling-- How are you feeling there, at ground zero, Justin?
Justin: Uh, yeah...I-- I, you know, I feel bad.
*laughing*
I mean, it would've been-- it would've been, you know, it wasn't me when it was someone else, so you know...
Here, here
People
Put in perspective we can feel too bad. Is he feeling any better. It's like he just went into a bit of a rage
Oh here you want some more? Yeah it's starting to get a little better. Ethan: Should we get a word from him?
Can we get a word from Joey? Let me get an update on his status.
How are you feeling
You okay?
Weird you're not okay, we're getting close to 75k buddy
Send your second intern with some water.
Ethan: You need water.
Hila: He wants water.
Joey: Yeah
Uh, we don't actually have an extra person
Go to the water fountain god dammit!
Evil is doing some guys do some research keep donating. This is all for charity guys
Know everybody hey, Joey
Thanks for doing what you did I mean, it's all good
I was just thanking you for all you've done for the people in Houston. I mean, this is a really symbolic
Callers in a single thing well not the strongest army are they
Guys you better be donating right now, I mean come on we're at 73,000 we got to hit 75 for Joey
He just took it as imagine a lot of pain. You know to make it worthwhile
Joey are you looking for water to drink or to what rinse your face?
We got water on the way, we have someone getting water for you, okay, Joe
All right so dry off and we'll see you soon, Joey
All right, I'll talk to you guys
Yep
Wow, that was special
That was before holy crap hey donations are back up right now. I
Want to get up to 75 K, because that's what this is for we wanted me to get to that number
That was kind of exceeded my expectation there what this dream could become
Joey salads got pepper sprayed by Justin roiland yeah, you're telling me or sprayed him in the fucking face. You're telling me
We're at 73 well, how are we not at 200,000? I know it's cuz of webpage crime you should be alive
about an hour
Now this man made a sacrifice Jesus
Well, we're gonna get him back in here. We'll talk
As he was screaming and crying did he say I love you easy
Is that some kind of like deep masochism? No it's kind of a moment of purity and trueness
It's a very complicated
At a label it be it's
Really like viscous
I kind of feel like I'm in like the Roman Colosseum like watching someone getting eaten by a lion like here
We are like eating great Julius Caesar delivered the water
Drink it
Don't spit it out. I spit it right out
I'm just trying not to vomit. I think you just try to distract yourself from the pain
Thank you guys, this is huge. Yeah, we got to upload this Joey sales clip by itself with the donation
Yeah, he's such a champ
Let me give you the backstory on this Joey sells because I'm kind of a novice to this well did the whole Joey stewards Joey
Salads backstories a whole journey, but I announced this charity stream about a week ago, and Joey texted me, and he's like yo
I want to come pepper spray myself. Well the charity stream, so it was his idea
Yeah, and I was like dude. I love it. I love it
What he said I don't know he's having a bit of a rage meltdown right now
He looks pretty fun yeah
This man shot are his eyes like swollen yes
We're gonna get a close-up look at those eyes
Once we get the milk off his body cuz you don't want it to smell like pepper spray and milk in here
That's my dream man that?
smells like pepper spray milk I
Think he's like tripping on acid right now
He's trying to describe his experience, but he's can't even come up short come on guys
we're at 74 thousand give Joey get up to 70 plus guy the least you could do is the whole
75 for what this guy just did we did it before
Before the donations cuz we did it in good faith. Yeah, we now we make it to 75 we knew would be worth it
We're getting close
I have a couple more videos on deck if you guys are wondering what's coming up next just pass 74. Whoo!
You always walked out of frame whoo? What a god. Wow.